[Music]
and a child is now blind because of
abuse he suffered it is a story the
i-team brought you in february
this evening we hear from the boy
himself our i-team's vanessa murphy has
a story you'll only see
right here on eight news now
life for marcus gray is different since
this photo was taken
the nine-year-old boy is now blind after
a beating with a belt
last november what did i do wrong to me
there's nothing that you could have ever
done
to deserve for this to happen to you
nothing
his paternal grandmother deborah evans
cares for him
metro police say akoya hudgins hit
marcus with a belt to discipline him
he was the live-in boyfriend of marcus's
mother gerashon jackson
even after they knew marcus was hurt
jackson didn't take him to the hospital
until six days later hudgins and jackson
were eventually arrested
hudgins apologized during this interview
with the i-team from jail in february
the kid like turned around like this
and i accidentally
a doctor explained in front of the grand
jury for injuries like marcus's
his eyesight may have been saved if he
had received
medical treatment sooner why didn't you
get him help
i to told her checked out you know to
see
how's ours are doing but i'm not the
parent so i can't go and take him
and get him checked out you're not the
parent
but you were hitting him with a belt
right yes
marcus is adapting to his new normal
last time
i could see shadows and up
and yeah shadows but now i can't
evan says he's learning braille now and
doing well in school
he spends time listening to music his
favorites
katy perry lady gaga and taylor swift
and he's a fan of the arts i like
ballet gymnastics
cheerleading he's very unique
he's a very unique little kid what does
that mean um
unique meaning that you do some
awesome stuff sometimes what do you want
to be when you grow up
i guess i want to be a
cheerleading group another wish surgery
so he can see again
evan says doctors say they've done what
they can but
she and marcus are holding on to hope he
was hurt nearly one year ago
for evans it's tough to think about
hudgens pleaded guilty to child abuse
and was sentenced 4-10 years in prison
jackson is awaiting trial evans says she
and marcus are taking it one day
at a time he should have never had to
ever experience none of this
vanessa murphy 8 news now deborah evans
says
marcus's teacher told her he is doing so
well in school
he could be in a gifted program